[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute haben wir eine tolle silvester
idee und zwar gfbv linken und zwar
faktisch vielleicht was es ist das ist
ein rinderfilet in einem blätterteig
mandeln und viele machen es immer so
dass die fertigen blätterteig nehmen ich
allerdings hat einen kindertag genommen
und zwar meinen selbstgemachten plunder
teig ist ein bisschen aufwendiger aber
markant im klondike schon vorher zu
bereiten und auch im gefrierfach lagern
von daher geht es dann auch von der
arbeit und innen drin ist das
rinderfilet noch ummantelt mit so na ja
so eine champignon fans genau und von
daher ist wirklich super lecker dazu
gibt es bei uns etwas rosenkohl und
karottengemüse einfach so als beilage
und wenn man möchte kann man auch noch
mit soße dazu servieren und ich finde es
perfekt für silvester weil man es gut
vorbereiten kann und im prinzip nur noch
kurz vor dem verzehr in den backofen
schieben muss und man kann es halt super
servieren für viele leute genau das will
jeder dritte etwas edles einher
also sieben das alltag man kann sein zu
alan ist als wir haben ihnen fahren
etwas besonderes und man kann natürlich
auch jeden tag essen aber schon was ich
zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten und
dann legen wir gleich los für das
wellington brauche ich ein stück
rinderfilet das hat etwa 1,2 kilo habe
ich zwei esslöffel butter schmalz 600
gramm champignons eine laufstarke einen
groß marien eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe
drei teelöffel senf ein eigelb und salz
und pfeffer und ich brauche dann
natürlich auch einen teig und die
meisten machen sollte ausfertigen
blätterteig das ist auch die einfachste
variante und es nicht zur zeit rauben
ich werd später allerdings meinen
selbstgemachten plunder teilnehmen und
flunder tag deswegen weil der einfach so
ein bisschen lockerer wird als
blätterteig aber blätterteig geht
natürlich auch jetzt nehme ich so erst
einmal
ich mache das die schnitzel aber ist
neben jetzt erst einmal die champignons
und hacke sie ganz fein und ihr könnt da
ist zum beispiel auch eine mixa nehmen
geht dann auch ein bisschen schneller
[Musik]
die champignons in zwei gehabt werde ich
auch die zwiebeln knoblauch zählen und
den lauf fein hacken oder nämlich jetzt
nicht im ganzen sondern etwa nur die
hälfte
[Musik]
hab ich alles schön fein gehackt jetzt
kommt das fleisch an die reihe
richtig schönes rinderfilet und da werde
ich jetzt ein stück wegschneiden damit
später einfach auch die form des bvl in
schönen gerade wird es da einfach
nachschauen ungefähr hier und den rest
kann ich ein klein schneiden und
einfrieren
wo es wieder was anderes daraus zaubern
werde ich hier schon mal eine pfanne
erhitzen und zwar nämlich als ein
paradies zum anbraten von fleisch
wirklich am besten geeignet und wird sie
jetzt auf mittlerer stufe erhitzen und
dann die temperatur hoch nehmen und die
pfanne solltet ihr auch niemals alleine
erhitzen sondern immer ein stück butter
oder öl mit rein geben damit sie einfach
nicht überhitzt
[Musik]
den rosmarinzweig gebe ich jetzt auch
mit rheinfest leckere aroma das fleisch
von allen seiten schön angefragten
richtig scharf so entstehen die tollen
röstaromen
[Musik]
das fleisch angebraten das habe ich
jetzt hier raus gelegt jetzt ist das
gemüse an der reihe und fürs gemüse
nehme ich jetzt eine beschichtete pfanne
die eignet sich dafür einfach etwas
besser da kommt jetzt auch noch schmalz
rein und das werde ich jetzt aber in mir
ich mach's in einer portion die große
portion etwas länger aber bei der
verschiedene ist ganz wichtig erste
nicht zu hoch erhitzt wird und dann
werde ich jetzt das gemüse darin
anbraten bis schön trocken ist also bis
die feuchtigkeit verdampft es man sieht
jetzt auch ganz deutlich hier das
jumping uns wirklich sehr viel
feuchtigkeit haben und die feuchtigkeit
muss dann eben raus
[Musik]
und während das gemüse gerät kann ich
schon mal das fleisch mit senf
bestreichen und mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich den selbst mit den
gewürzen noch ein bisschen ein damit ein
profil salz und pfeffer drauf ist
[Musik]
das gemüse ist schön trocken jetzt kann
ich noch würzen mit salz pfeffer und ich
gebe noch ein bisschen viel mit rein das
passt ganz gut zu den champignons
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich es fertig gewürzt und
jetzt übrigens auch fahrt
da schmerzt mich nicht was es ist sagte
es sieht komisch aus und zieht nicht
komisch vor leckere und liebe pips wales
und jetzt kommt diese farce und
rinderfilet herum und entweder könnte
das jetzt einfach so machen geht aber
bisschen schwierig deswegen nehme ich
jetzt in der chemie passt immer und zwar
bei mich dass es so ist dieser winter
schenken den findet man wirklich in
allen typischen supermärkten ein film
zuschlag logisch abonniert oder mein
rock hat geht im einkauf fast immer und
außen rum nach außen rum ist so temmen
und des box von klassischen ganz ganz
tolles gewürzt was stinkt zwar drei
jahren verliehen der in der europäischen
küche tempel ist ja nicht so dass
wirklich ganz genau was wir essen ja
keinen speck oder schinken speck und ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch schinken speck
ja genau
das lege ich jetzt hier überlappend hin
ist es auch ein gewisses ist es kommt
durch ganz neue forderte gegessen habt
etwas ganz ganz besonderes müssen wir
probieren zwei schichten und es hilft
mir gleich dabei dass ich diese fahr
richtig gut um das fleisch herum bekomme
[Musik]
ist da einfach nur schauen dass es genau
so breit oder bisschen für ein bisschen
breiter ist als das fleisch
da kommt jetzt die fast auf
die wird jetzt hier schon verstrichen
[Musik]
so ein kleines stück hier unten las ich
frei da kommt jetzt das fleisch drauf
jetzt kann ich mithilfe der folie
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch hier
drunter das fleisch schön ein rolle
ist wirklich jetzt hier noch mal drum
herum und so bekommt das fleisch ist
einfach eine schöne form und ich wette
noch mal im kühlschrank abkühlen lassen
für etwa eine halbe stunde
denn wenn ich jetzt so warm auf meinen
bruder teig gebe dann wird die butter im
grunde tag warm und das möchte ich nicht
daher kommt das jetzt so erstmal in den
kühlschrank voll aus
[Musik]
das fleisch ist jetzt gut durchgekämpft
und ich habe jetzt hier meinen flunder
teig der bereits gut gekühlt ist und
davon habe ich jetzt 700 gramm genommen
also von meinem grundrezept und jetzt
rolle stehen auf etwa 35 x 45 cm aus und
falls sie jetzt hier fertigen
blätterteig nimmt müsst ihr denn auch
ausrollen also ein bisschen größer
ausrollen auch 35 x 45
[Musik]
darum habe ich jetzt einen streifen
weggeschnitten die nehme ich nämlich
noch für die dekoration und der tiger
schutz etwa 0 5 zentimeter dick und
jetzt schneide ich das fleisch hier raus
[Musik]
das fleisch tickets etwa im unteren
drittel und schmidts eingerollt und die
ränder werden jetzt mit bisschen
eingestrichen
[Musik]
und hier am rand das können wir jetzt
entscheiden wie jetzt machen möchten
entweder drückt ihr es einfach zusammen
oder fall für ein geschenkpaket zusammen
rücksitz zusammen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich nochmal ein bisschen rand
weg das sieht einfach ein bisschen
hübscher aus und drückt mit der gabel
zusammen erst mal auf meinen backblech
und zwar ist hier mein perforiert es
wackelt und träge ist jetzt um so dass
ich einfach diese komplett glatte seite
oben habe und ups unten nochmal auf das
backblech von meinem backofen nämlich
deswegen weil es einfach im ofen sein
kann das mittel fleischsaft fleischsaft
auftritt und das ganze so ein bisschen
tropft und so bleibt der backofen schön
sauber
und aus den resten werde ich jetzt ein
paar dekorationen machen
ihr könnt jetzt zum beispiel falls es
für semester sein soll die zahl 2017
drauf schreiben oder auch blätter
ausschneiden oder herzchen ausstechen
und das ganze eben schon zu ziehen und
damit auch alles schön draufkleben
bleibt nämlich jetzt das eigelb gibt
auch noch ein esslöffel wasser mit rein
und bestreicht dann auch komplett der
mitte hat eine richtig schöne goldbraune
farbe
[Musik]
vorkommt das gremium jetzt bei 210 grad
ober unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen etwa 35 bis 40 minuten
wie gesagt ich habe hier das blech
runter kommt einfach nicht in den ofen
reindrückt und in der zwischenzeit werde
ich schon in zwei lagen vorbereiten
zum belegten gibt jetzt gleich ein
bisschen gemüse dazu und so habe ich
jetzt hier schon mal 500 gramm rosenkohl
hier ein bund möhren etwas salz pfeffer
olivenöl muskat und zucker ich zeig euch
jetzt mal ganz kurz wie man den großen
und verarbeitet und zwar millionen den
stängel wegschneiden der ist jetzt hier
schon weg dann wird er hier eingesetzt
und die äußeren blätter die nimmt mal
auch weg also wenn man sieht dass die so
ein bisschen hier so hübsch sind
nimmt man die einfach darunter und
rosenkohl ist echt richtig unterstützt
also ich mag es sehr gerne mag es
eigentlich gar nicht aber ich glaube
dass einfach er ist seine kindheit
begeistert wenn es eben nicht richtig
zubereitet wurde
[Musik]
hab ich ihn auch noch kurz abgewaschen
jetzt nehme ich die möhren und dem die
nehme ich auch immer ganz gerne mit grün
das grün könnt ihr auch nehmen zum
beispiel für smoothies das schrecklich
super lecker und gesund und die schneide
gezogen dass er oben so ein bisschen
grün noch da bleibt einfach für die
optik
[Musik]
sie werden jetzt noch geschält und dann
auch abgewaschen und in der zeit kann
ich hier im topf schon mal ein bisschen
wasser aufkochen
denn ich werde jetzt gleich günstig
[Musik]
die karotten hall welche so sieht
richtig hübsch aus wenn man dann das
immer so ein bisschen sieht hab ich hier
etwas wasser im topf und hier oben
diesem fall gibt da kann ich nämlich
richtig gut drin dünsten
die karotten kommen jetzt zuerst rein
die sind ja ein bisschen fester die
definiert mit geschlossenem deckel
aircraft vier minuten garen
bis dann der rotkohl auf mich zukommt
und jetzt gebe ich noch den rosenkohl
dazu und dann darf der noch mal etwa
fünf bis sechs minuten mit gammen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich zuerst in rhoden wohl
raus habe jetzt hier schon mal ein
bisschen olivenöl in einer pfanne
erhitzt und ihr könnt es jetzt entweder
zusammen an paten tochter getrennt
ich mache es jetzt getrennt damit ich
bei den karotten noch ein bisschen einen
anderen geschmack mit reinbekommen zum
rosenkohl kommt eine prise zucker dazu
der rotenburger so ein bisschen fitter
und durch den zucker geht es bittere so
ein bisschen weg dies wird durch
schwenken
mit salz pfeffer und muskat würzen
[Musik]
und da reicht auch schon aus wenn er
einfach kurz geschwenkt wird
denn die feier schon jetzt nehme ich die
gleiche pfanne
da kommt noch ein bisschen olivenöl
rhein etwas honig
[Musik]
eine fein geschnittene knoblauchzehe
erst krone heraus kräften das jetzt kurz
anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es da ganz vorsichtig die
karotten mit dazu
[Musik]
die werden jetzt auch noch mit salz und
pfeffer gewürzt und dann muss ich mir
noch überlegen war
[Musik]
das blinken ist jetzt fertig wir müssen
beachten
ich habe bei mir das backblech also das
zweite paket direkt unterm ein lochblech
gemacht und dadurch war der lift
luftzirkulation natürlich nicht mehr so
gut deswegen ist jetzt länger drin und
das untere blech sind auch irgendwann
weg am besten ist es ihr legt das untere
blech einfach auf den backofen boden so
kann einfach die luft unter dem bevor
linken immer noch zirkulieren und ist
dann eben auch perfekt von der zeit her
und wenn ihr es ganz perfekt haben wollt
nehmt ihr ein fleisch thermometer und
sticht an einer unauffälligen stelle
hinten rein und wenn wenn es im inneren
etwa 60 grad haben ist perfekt nach dem
backen lässt es aber etwa zehn minuten
liegen
und jetzt warten wir schon gespannt
darauf auf das ergebnis
es ist ja auch wieder backofen anders
genau also im prinzip müssten also
einmal ausprobieren in eurem backofen
und aber im prinzip sind 35 40 wirklich
perfekt und falls ihr fleisch
thermometer habt geht es damit auch
super aber ich nehme ihn brotmesser
bisschen besser jetzt hier oben ich
schneide jetzt mal ein großzügiges stück
[Musik]
bei mir war es leider zu lange drin also
muss ich sagen ich hatte das problem in
meinem backofen und war habe ich ja das
blech runde gehabt und es war halt am
anfang wirklich gar nicht durch und ich
hab dann im braten thermometer hinten
rein gestochen an einer unauffälligen
stelle und es war halt wirklich noch gar
nicht ansatzweise durch gegart oder an
gegart und deswegen habe ich jetzt
länger drin daher ist es nicht mehr rosa
aber ich denke im rat ist es trotzdem
schön fand ich so gut wie leer ist
allerdings falsch machen das stimmt es
ist natürlich schade aber normalerweise
wirklich 35 minuten 40 minuten vor allem
ist auch so manche möchten sagt gar
nicht erst stimmt alles für meine mama
das ist so perfekt
aber wenn ersten medium haben möchtest
dann schnallt sich durch anzeigen wolle
es riecht auch schon zu aber ich habe
trotzdem gern ruhe
super wirklich super es ist sehr bitter
aus dem schlachtfeld ich habe das nicht
so schönen kirche in dresden war so
nicht ganz
aber erinnern sie zweck ist schon raus
einfach genial keine kamera aufnehmen
also es ist für leute die jetzt muss
erst was heißt es ist durch es ist durch
zurück obwohl es so man muss dazu sagen
ich habe es zwar länger drin gehabt aber
ich habe es natürlich auf 100 grad
runter gestellt dass er glaubt dass die
immer noch sehr sehr zartes fleisch und
schmeckt einfach genial ag sieht auch
ihr liebster hast pastelle die ganze
klasse absolut hast deine eltern der
super die mögen michaelimarkt läge das
nächste mal für uns denke ich nur 35
minuten back vielleicht ganz unten oder
im prinzip könnt ihr auch einfach dauer
back folie unten in den backofen
reinlegen
dreckig und selbst wenn der tisch ist
egal oder für den geschmack
ein kauf nehmen wollte das rezept gerne
nachmachen wohlstand geht auf sase -
blog.de da stets nummer für euch schaut
euch auch das flunder teig video an
und wenn es nach macht würde ich mich
freuen wenn ihr mehr ein foto auf
facebook app instagram schickt und uns
ein feedback geht also bis zum nächsten
mal schön ist investor feier
[Musik]